good morning actually i don't know what
time it is for you it's it's morning for
me well welcome to the presentation on
slope and y intercept this presentation
isn't going to
teach you how to solve for slope and y
intercept but hopefully it will give you
a good intuition of what slope and
y-intercept is and we're gonna do a
little bit uh something a little bit
different uh this time as opposed to
what we normally do we're not gonna use
the chalk we're actually gonna go on to
the khan academy website and use one of
the uh use the graph of a line exercise
to get a little bit of an intuition for
what a slope and y intercept is so when
when the application starts off it
starts with the equation y equals one x
plus one so that's the same thing as y
equals x plus one but we see that the
slope here is one if you if you looked
at the introduction to graphing i talked
about that the slope is the same thing
as the coefficient on the
on the x term and if you see here
whenever we move over by one
we move up by one and i'm going to do
another module on that slope is actually
rise over run so it's for every amount
you rise how much do you have to run to
get that and rise just means how much do
you change in y run means how much do
you change in x so here rise over run is
just one and y-intercept is where you
intersect the y-axis now as i change the
slope and the y-intercept for this graph
i think it's going to make a little bit
more sense to you watch what happens
when the slope goes from
one to three-halves so three halves is
the same thing as one and a half so
notice it got steeper and if i increase
the steep slope more it gets deeper even
more that's y equals 2x
if i increase it anymore five halves is
two and a half so the more i increase
the slope i think you see what's
happening this thing jumps around i
should fix that
let me move it back and actually the
goal is to make is to make the line um
match those go through those two blue
points that's the goal of i guess you
call the game let's see i don't like how
this thing jumps around though that was
interesting let me go back there this is
let me go back y equals zero x plus one
so we could have written just we could
have rewritten this as just y equals one
because zero
is the same thing as 0. notice it's a
completely flat line no matter what x is
y is 1. and that makes sense because
this equation would just be y equals 1.
now i've been showing you what happens
to the slope let's see now notice we
have a negative slope the slope is now
downward sloping it's downward sloping
it at a slope of one half because the
rod let's say the rise in the situation
is negative one and the run is two so
that's why we get negative one over two
and we have we've just been doing slope
so far and i think you get the idea that
as we decrease slope it's going to push
the line further and further it's gonna
slope downward even more i hate to use
the a word in its own definition but um
i think you see that now the picture now
let's put the y-intercept a little bit
this is even more interesting so
y-intercept
oh boy how did that happen
that was strange
what y-intercept notice
negative 1x plus 2 so the slope is
negative 1 but it intersects the y-axis
of 2. now if we if we increase the
y-intercept by one more it's just going
to push this line up one let's do that
oh well this is actually increasing it
by increments of one half
let's do another one i just want to see
what happens on another graph because it
actually depends on the actual problem
okay this is interesting why okay this
is the same thing we start at the same
point let's actually try to
go into these two
actually figure out the equation of the
line that goes through these two points
well let's see it looks like the
y-intercept's going to have to be a
little bit lower
well i didn't know i could it would do
that
notice we just it just brings the line
down as we as we lower the y-intercept
and let's see i think the slope needs to
be higher because those two points the
line that goes through them is
definitely
steeper i apologize for this thing
acting up like that that looks like
about the right slope because the slope
is like that and these two points are
connected yeah that's i think that looks
like the right slope but the y intercept
has to be lower
let's see
almost there i think
there you go
so the equation of this line is 7 4 x so
7 4 that's the same thing as like 1.75
so the slope of this line
slopes faster than
one over one and you can kind of see
that and we'll i'll show you how to
figure out all of this i just want to
give you an intuitive sense of what
slope and y-intercept is and it
intersects the y-axis at negative 13
over four that's a little more than
three which you can
negative three which you can you can see
right there
let's see if we can do another one let's
see
and and if you want we can assign this
module to you and you can play with it
just like i'm doing right here so let's
see the line that we want to get will go
something like that so it looks like the
current line slope is a little too high
so let me lower the slope a little bit
that looks about right
7 8 x so that means for every 8 you move
to the right you're going to move seven
up and i'm going to draw that better in
another module this module i'm kind of
doing on the fly so i apologize
i do every i do every module on the fly
so i guess i really should apologize
but you're not paying for this so i
shouldn't apologize oh anyway
i get distracted very easily let's see
let's move this line up and you do that
just by the y-intercept you can see
shifting the y-intercept up just shifts
the line straight up it doesn't change
the inclination of the line the slope
changes the inclination of the line
there we go the equation of this line is
7 8 x plus 13 over 4. let's see if what
i said about slope is right if we move
if we run 8 we should rise seven so
let's see run eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven eight so that gets us right there
and then we should rise seven
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven well that actually gets us those
exact points and we're back on the line
again i'm gonna draw another thing like
that for you so
if you get confused don't don't lose
heart let's let's do one more
okay
where's the other dot i don't know i
have a
let me see
well the other dot doesn't exist yeah i
gotta fix all these bugs in this thing
oh they're good it showed up it showed
up excellent okay so look this we have
to make the line go through these two
points it looks like the slope is
negative definitely not that negative
it's like a fractional negative slope
and it'll intercept the y-axis somewhere
around here so the y-intercept's going
to be like 7 and something
7 and change so first of all let's get
this slope down of what this thing's
going to jump around again
notice y equals zero x plus one if we
increase the slope
what this thing is doing also i haven't
seen this application in a while so
i must have written it when i had
inferior programming skills let's see
let me keep
okay that slope might be right let's
let's bring the line up higher
now still seems like my slope
so the y-intercept i'm raising the line
oh good i got it exactly right and i was
right the slope is negative because you
can see it slopes downward but it's not
sloping downward that fast and that
makes sense if the slope is negative
one-third and that makes sense because
if we
if we
run three
one
two
three
we rise negative one
we rise negative one right there so
that's why the slope is negative
one-third and then the y-intercept is 22
over three well that's seven and
one-third and
right there we intersect the y-axis
one-third of the way between
seven and eight
well i think
that should at least give you a little
bit of an intuition on on what slope and
y intercept are and i can actually uh
you can you can have this module
assigned for you so you could you could
play with it yourself and i'm going to
do some more modules we actually
calculate slope and y intercept and and
hopefully give you even
further intuition on what they are so
i hope you have fun uh playing around
with this stuff it's actually uh i
remember i was very excited when i first
learned this stuff it's very visual i'll
have fun